in this tutorial i'm going to show you
three effects in after effects that will
help polish your work and make it look
more
[Music]
professional my name is cameron with
motion science and in this video i'm
going to show you the three effects that
i love to use to finish every project i
work on these are three effects that are
built into after effects so we all have
them and they can take your work up a
notch so whether you're a beginner or an
advanced user check out these three
effects that you should be using okay
here we are in after effects and you can
see here i've got this preview going of
a project i'm calling line this is a
project from the stylecraft course and
to make this project move along a little
bit faster i'm going to go ahead and
turn off depth of field so we can see
everything
nice and clear here
like we see here
so how i like to finish
every project i work on is i use three
effects over the top of everything and
how i do that typically is i go to layer
new
adjustment layer and i like to call this
effects and the very first effect i like
to apply is under effect blur and
sharpen
gaussian blur and typically i like to
use a value of gaussian blur between 1
and 3 pixels so typically i'll start
with a value of 1
and i'll look and see
you know is it making much difference
what i'm trying to do here is eliminate
some of the harsh edges
of this being you know a digital art
piece
so if i go from one to three
that's too much blur for me right there
off the top i can see it's too much blur
so then maybe i'll drop it back down to
a two that looks okay maybe i'll try a
1.5
there's a little bit too much aliasing
happening here
so i'll go back to a2
and right off the top that's looking
better to me so that's with blur
and without it's a very subtle change
but it's just enough to make this look
less digital you can really see it up in
here
so if i zoom in here
if i turn the blur off
just look how crystal clear that is
and i don't want that right i want
something that looks a little bit more
organic so that's why i'm applying blur
here so that's the first effect i apply
is gaussian blur
next i will go and i will apply glow now
typically i like to use a few different
glows
some of my favorites are sapphire
s glow is a great one
but for this one i am going to use
plug-in everything deep glow
and
right off the top it's overpowering this
is something that i see a lot with deep
glow it's just a lot of glow right off
the top and i like to play around with
typically the radius and the exposure
for this project i found that just
dropping the
exposure down to about a point
three seven let's take it a little bit
further down it's always less is more on
finishing touches like this
and if you can't really tell there's a
lot of glow happening here that's really
winning the cause for me so that's with
deep glow that's without uh maybe even a
little bit less
yeah so it's just enough to make it just
a little bit more interesting let's
actually go point zero five
and that's without and that's with and
the third effect i like to add is under
noise and grain and we're going to add
grain we can either add grain or we can
add noise it really just depends on the
project
and how it's looking to be and sometimes
adding grain
can do some funky things to the preview
and this is a great example of that
happening so i'm gonna delete add grain
i'm gonna go to layer new
adjustment layer
we're just gonna call this one grain
and to this one we're going to apply add
grain
like i said sometimes it just acts a
little funky i hate to put on its own
adjustment layer we'll change it from
preview to final output
and we're going to zoom in here
and look and right off the top you can
tell it's very subtle there right it's
very very subtle let's try a preset
let's just try color negative two
there's a lot of grain there i'm gonna
open up color and i'm gonna select
monochromatic because this is a black
and white project
and zoom out here
and let's drop the intensity to about
0.5
maybe even
0.3 again this is very subtle in the
effects here but it's the subtleties
that make all the difference for
a really finished piece
and let me add in one fourth effect this
is your bonus effect that i throw in on
a lot of projects but not all projects
and that is
chromatic aberration
two different plugins i like to use for
this is plug and everything quick
chromatic aberration or sapphire distort
warp chroma and apply that and then
we're actually even going to turn this
down just
a hair so we'll go from 0.97 to 0.99
and it's very very subtle again
and let's go ahead and preview this and
that my friends is three plus one bonus
effect that i use every single time to
finish my projects
in after effects i hope that you really
enjoyed this lesson as much as i loved
teaching it so please let me know if you
have any questions in the comments below
i'd love to answer them for you hit that
like button if you enjoyed this video
and please subscribe to this channel it
helps other people find this channel as
well if you're looking to upgrade your
design skill set master the art of style
and execute like a pro i have a course
called stylecraft that you can check out
at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
you